paye aujourd'hui on va parler deux
choses on va parler du eric 17 neo 2 au
pot on veut aussi parler de north bay pn
je vous parlais de cybersécurité parce
que c'est un plan qui est hyper
important pour la première minute de la
vidéo mais surtout du nouveau smartphone
de au pot se présenter les deux lors de
la conf de presse a pas très longtemps
qu'ils aient lieu à paris maintenant je
vous parlais du rx 17 neo qui a plein
d'atouts hyper intéressant et surtout
dans sa gamme de prix c'est vraiment un
excellent smartphone
[Musique]
mais avant je vous parlais de cyber
sécurité parce que c'est une vie dès
aujourd'hui qui est sponsorisé par
d'ordres et pme
pourquoi je vous parle de cybersécurité
simplement parce que c'est très
important d'être vraiment sensibiliser
au fait de sécuriser ses données pour
vraiment accroître votre sécurité pour
éviter de vous faire pirater que vos
données soient collectées récupérer
voilà il ya plein de choses qui sont
hyper hyper importante que ce soit avec
un ordinateur avec une tablette avec un
smartphone dakar ou tort il faut
vraiment penser aujourd'hui sécurité de
vos données
c'est hyper hyper hyper important d'où
le fait de vous parler aujourd'hui de
north défaite est ce qu'un vpn avait
peine si vous voulez il faut imaginer
lorsque vous connecter à internet vous
connecter votre ordinateur en gros un
site et vous donner peut être intercepté
et surtout surtout sur les wifi public
mcdo hôtel aéroport wii fit ville et
compagnie vos données peuvent être très
facilement récupéré par des hackers donc
là pour le coup d'autant plus exposés
comme une dinde à noël docly offert
hyper gaffe
l'idée d'un vpn si vous voulez c'est que
ça va créer entre vous et le vpn un
tunnel complètement en crypté hyper
sécurisé et impénétrable dans lequel vos
données seront hyper sécurisé et on
pourra pas le tue les récupérer donc ça
c'est hyper hyper important c'était que
votre ip et protégé on ne sait pas qui
vous êtes on sait pas où vous êtes on ne
sais pas qu'est-ce que vous consultez on
ne sait pas ce que vous téléchargez bref
vous êtes protégé
en gros il faut l'imaginer comme un
bouclier face aux risques du web et face
au piratage
norbi pn fonctionne bien évidemment sur
windows sur mac sur ios sur android sur
linux sur android tv et avec un seul et
même abonnement vous pouvez connecter
jusqu'à six appareils
en gros vous prenez un abonnement et
vous protéger l'ensemble de votre foyer
ça c'est vraiment cool et en plus de ça
il ya les extensions qui existent pour
firefox et pour chrome
autant dire que c'est vraiment hyper
facile à mettre en place vous pouvez si
vous téléchargez l'application sur le
plat store ou sur l'app store
je vous invite vraiment à rien et ça
très sérieusement parce que les
questions de cybersécurité c'est hyper
hyper hyper hyper important et ça va
être encore plus dans les années à venir
d'ailleurs vous permettre de le
découvrir
je vous ai mis un lien en bas avec un
code promo le code c grrrr j'ai peur
vous permettra de prendre un abonnement
ça vous coûtera que deux dollars 99 par
mois et en plus vous aurez un mois
offerts et vous aurez un total de 75 %
de remise sur votre abonnement
franchement ça c'est un super bon plan
et en termes de rapidité
ça va ça carbure parce qu'ils ont honte
ou 5100 serveurs dispatchés dans 62 pays
donc en gros où vous soyez dans le globe
vous êtes protégé parlons maintenant du
rx 17 neo 2 au pot gelé là il est beau
il est chaud il est dans ma poche
j'ai beaucoup alors avant de vous parler
directement du smartphone de vous
expliquer un peu comment il est comment
il fonctionne ce qu'il apporte ci et ça
on va d'abord regarder un petit peu le
contenu de la boîte plutôt cool
bon c'est pas révolutionnaire mais c'est
plutôt cool et ce qui est vraiment très
intéressant est vraiment la chose à
retenir tout au long de cette vidéo
c'est que de comprendre que c'est un
smartphone qui coûte 349 euros donc on
veut faire plein de choses pour 349
euros et c'est vraiment l'adn de ce
produit c'est d'apporter des techno qui
sont dans le haut de gamme sur un
smartphone milieu de gamme et vous allez
voir quand c'est pas mal aller en rien
la botte rx 17 nouveaux on est un peu
comme sur le pro même typologie de boîte
très simple côté un petit peu relief là
c'est sympa eric dès cette année au bond
les smartphones j'ai déjà sorti là vous
avez une coque transparente au pot avec
de la doc avec le nécessaire pour votre
tiroir de carte sim au paf charger ici
paire d'écouteurs a qu'une petite prise
jack parce que le smartphone à une prise
jack donc ça c'est cool et la recharge
par contre là dessus se fait en micro
usb il n'y a pas de recharge rapide sur
ce smartphone si vous voulez d'un
recharge rapide il faut aller sur le
modèle pro c'est simple c'est efficace
ça marche bien
maintenant on va regarder le smartphone
de plus près et vous allez voir il a
vraiment énormément de points positifs
là il est dispo dans la couleur qu'ils
appellent le rouge mots chat je pense
que c'est une espèce de traduction parce
que c'est vrai que le terme au chat et à
très très beau pas vendeur mais malgré
tout c'est un bon modèle après vous avez
aussi le bleu strahl qui est très très
très très sympa que j'ai pu voir lors de
la présentation ce rouge boschat il a
vraiment un côté très sympa c'est à dire
que vous avez en réalité un
gradé 3d vous le voyez avec la lumière
ça donne un aspect de relief c'est
franchement franchement cool
vous avez un dos vera corning gorilla
glass 5 que vous avez ici à l'arrière
mais vous avez aussi l avant donc ça ça
lui confère vraiment des propriétés de
solidité
néanmoins c'était quand même une petite
protection à l'avant et à l'arrière
parce que s'il tombe il a beau avoir un
corning gorilla glass 5 qui devrait
quand même se casser ça sera quand même
relativement dommages au point qui coule
et qui est positif vous avez signe
toutes petites encoches agent proche de
fin 2018 en cochant goutte d'eau est ici
là sur le dessus vous avez le petit haut
parleur qui vachement bien intégré sache
que ceux ci une très très belle réussite
sur cette fin d'année
bon après reste du design est assez
classique vous avez un bouton sur la
tranche la dc prise jack micro usb ici
haut parleur mono de ce côté bouton de
volume ici tiroirs de cartes sim dans
lequel vous allez pouvoir ranger double
sim plus extension carte micro sd donc
ça c'est cool sur le dessus rien si ce
n'est le petit micro voilà donc à
l'arrière double module photo flash led
vous le voyez là vous avez ici un
déverrouillage avec capteur d'empreintes
digitales directement intégré à l'écran
ça c'est les techno qu'on peut retrouver
dans le mail d'un pro dans gone plus ce
système qui coûte beaucoup plus cher
j'appuie ça marche hyper rapidement je
glisse vers le haut c'est franchement
cool alors sans plus vous pouvez le
combiné avec le déverrouillage spatiale
homme je me décale un peu de l'appareil
j'appuie ça me reconnaissent à
déverrouille directement face à un point
qui est vraiment très très très positif
et même le déverrouillage à la
reconnaissance directement faciale
marche super bien
voyez c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
bien points maintenant qui est super
cool sur ce smartphone c'est son écran
vous avez un écran amoled de 6,4 pouces
avec une résolution de 2340 par 1080
pixels 402 pixels par pouce et un écran
qui occupent 91% de la face avant
ça c'est aussi un point extrêmement
positif d'abord un écran oled de cette
qualité dans cette gamme de prix
c'est franchement énorme il est
franchement extrêmement lumineux il a
vraiment très très belle qualité et il a
un menton qui est vraiment ridicule donc
il occupe quasiment quasiment la
totalité de la face avant
ça c'est aussi excellent dans sa gamme
de prix en termes de performance je
trouve vraiment vraiment vraiment hyper
hyper réactif vous avez un snapdragon
664 giga de ram typiquement sur un jeu
comme pib et c'est vrai qu'il marche
plutôt pas mal alors après ce que je
vais lui reprocher par moments c'est
qu'il va la vie un petit peu
de l'autre côté on est sur un snapdragon
cent soixante on n'est pas sur le
smartphone le plus puissant du marché
pour ce type de jeu on qualité graphique
collections de qualité moyenne bon ça va
néanmoins vous pouvez jouer je sais pas
pourquoi il ya des pièces des maisons
dans lesquelles je ne peux pas entrer
voilà allez savoir pourquoi je ne sais
pas je ne comprends toujours pas ça je
sais pas ce qui se passe si vous êtes un
joueur pb j'ai voulu marquer en
commentaire parce que je trouve ça
vraiment vraiment bizarre côté gpu
hommes et une adreno 512 ça marche côté
graphique franchement je pense que ça
fait vraiment son affaire vous avez là
tu seras 28 juillet de stockage que vous
pouvez monter jusqu'à 256 grâce à une
carte micro sd
ça marche bien ça canarde de tous les
côtés ceci donne clank et parce qu il
sent que je prends une balle je ne
trouve pas l'entrée la maison à elle et
la voilà à l'acheteur entrée qu'est-ce
qui est alors voilà donc ça c'est cool
donc voilà pour un jeu de type pib j'ai
franchement ça marche bien d'ailleurs il
l'avait annoncé en août posent sur leur
site en 10 ans chez nous paye bg ça va
très très bien marché bah je me fais
jamais allée bouge c'est un carnage je
sors côté de nomi c'est pas mal
batterie 3600 millions terreur vous la
gardez une journée sans aucun problème
ça dépend bien évidemment complètement
de votre utilisation une fois de plus
l'autonomie c'est un truc un petit peu
compliqué a donné par rapport à une
utilisation standard que ce smartphone
en tout cas moi je les garde une journée
sans aucun problème alors je ne suis pas
un sauvage dessus j'étais pas tout le
temps dessus en train de jouer en train
d'envoyer des messages sur les réseaux
sociaux toute la journée pour
l'utilisation gérer un peu classique ça
tient sans aucun problème maintenant ce
que j'aime moins sur celui là par
rapport aux pros c'est que vous n'avez
pas de recharge rapide
alors il va surcharger faut quand même
un peu de patience c'est du micro usb
voilà on peut pas non plus tout avoir
dans cette gamme de prix là le lot est
ce je vous en avais déjà parlé c'est un
color os 5.2 qui tourne sur un android
8.1 oreo bon ça marche que j'aime bien
moi ch un peu de mal à échapper la balle
ici on a un petit tiroir avec vos
applications récentes applications
favori pour faire des captures d'écran
assez facilement vous glisser à trois
doigts vous fait une capture d'écran ça
c'est cool pour faire des captures écran
nombre dans la salle j'en ai déjà parlé
dans la vidéo du rx 17 pro en termes de
photos vous avez à l'arrière ici un
double module photo 16 mégapixels + 2
mégapixels le premier 16 mégapixels
ouvre à f 1.7 le 2
2 mégapixels à f 2.4 il servira pour le
mode portrait tandis qu'à l'avant vous
avez une caméra de 25 méga pixels il ya
un vrai beau boulot qui est fait au
niveau des photos je trouve qu'il ya
vrai vrai vrai vrai détail dans les
images les couleurs sont assez bien
restituer la regardez moi ça soit
vraiment beau c'est très tonique il ya
un vrai point de détail au niveau de
l'image
alors c'est pas non plus la photo la
plus folles vont pouvoir trouver mais
dans cette gamme de prix
je trouve qu'elle est vraiment vraiment
vraiment bien ça je sais que zoom x 2 on
a vraiment des détails là il ya un vrai
beau travail au niveau de l'image et au
niveau du traitement de l'image les
couleurs sont vraiment bien restituée
l'armée sur une photo sur les caméras de
seule fille ça fonctionne ça c'est le
mode portrait le détourage je trouve
bien c'est bien d'éviter qu'on voit
qu'on n'est pas sur le stand dragon 845
sauf que le 660 fait vraiment bon boulot
là dessus là je sens les caméras de
saïfi et je trouve vraiment que cet
appareil est assez bluffant pour son
tarif là je peux filmer uniquement en
1080p ou en 720p
ça me pose pas trop de problème on est
sur une caméra cette fille je trouve que
les photos rendre vraiment bien la
qualité est là on a vraiment du point de
détail sauf qu'ils ont vraiment une
finesse au niveau de l'image maintenant
on va faire un test vidéo sur cette
fameuse caméra arrière sur la caméra
mais hier lâche plus en plus filmer en
4k je passe surtout soit nécessairement
indispensable sur de 1080p comme c'est
là tout de suite ça fonctionne
relativement bien je trouve vraiment
complet ce smartphone pour marc c'est un
smartphone milieu de gamme on à double
carte sim cartes microsd prise jack nfc
bluetooth 5.0 pour moi là dessus il ya
vraiment deux gros point positif le tout
premier c'est son écran 6 4 pouces oled
dans cette gamme de prix c'est
imbattable il marche extrêmement bien
sûr du fhd plus et en plus ce que je
trouve vraiment bien aussi c'est ce
capteur d'empreinte digitale intégrée à
l'écran ça marche bien alors c'est
capteur d'empreintes digitales sont
toujours un peu moins rapide que ce que
vous avez version un peu plus classique
à l'arrière ou sur les côtés des
smartphones on voit que c'est la grosse
tendance fin 2018 c'est vraiment un
smartphone pour des personnes qui
veulent pas dépenser trop d'argent dans
leurs smartphones 349 euros vous avez un
écran qui est vraiment exigeant vous
avez un smartphone qui est suffisamment
puissant avec le cendre aegon 660 vous
avez
stockage 128 giga extensible ça c'est
vraiment cool et vous avez
déverrouillage avec le capteur
d'empreintes digitales situé sous
l'écran couplée à la caméra avant ça
marche bien c'est ma vie de ces
pratiques pour moi c'est un smartphone
qui se destine à tous ceux qui veulent
pas dépenser trop d'argent dans leurs
produits mais qu'ils veulent quand même
un produit exigeant qui fait de bonnes
photos qui est vraiment un produit très
complet je trouve vraiment cool dites
moi vous ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire comment vous trouvez ce au
pot rx 17 neo
comment vous trouvez le pro également
gelé par là aussi il ya quelques temps
dites moi tout ça en commentaire on en
discute ensemble et je vous invite comme
d'hab à aller consulter ma playlist pour
découvrir tous les smartphones du moment
voir un petit peu ce qui se fait en ce
moment et vous allez voir il ya
franchement plein de modèles ils sont
hyper cool
j'invite heitz agen prenez soin de vous
et puis je vous dis à demain ciao